okay I think I'm live sometimes takes a
few seconds never really clear when but
I think I'm live welcome to the live
stream a lot to talk about we'll be
talking about Donald Trump's propaganda
evening address tomorrow Tuesday we will
be talking about the latest with Ruth
Bader Ginsberg which you know all those
leftists who were saying there's no
practical difference between Trump and
Hillary doesn't really matter who wins
they're both corporate shills or
whatever Supreme Court's proving to be a
pretty good sort of Exhibit A as to why
it mattered and why it still matters so
we will get to all of that stuff I do
have some new stuff going on you might
notice that up here where is it now over
here I have this list of stuff so these
are I think I don't know if these are
actually real or just placeholders but
anyway when people do stuff when people
pledge on patreon or send Super chats
with questions or whatever they'll come
up up here and then the other thing I
have going let's see if this works when
you send a super chat let's see there it
is you're super chat will come up and
then it will actually stay on for a
little bit giving me a chance to read it
and if they start coming in so fast and
furious that I don't have a chance to
respond to each before the next one
comes up that's a really great problem
to have and will will will hope that
that happens and what else do I have if
you become a Youtube member which is
it's a beta test that we're part of you
can hit the join button and become a
Youtube member that will pop up I guess
it's still called the sponsor and then
if you pledge on patreon that also will
pop up now these are all just tests so I
don't know if they'll actually work but
as they start coming in I guess I guess
we'll see we'll see if they work and
what else did I want to go over oh I
should do my if this is your first David
Pakman show
live stream because most of the stuff we
do is not live were uploading clips from
our broadcast television and radio show
to YouTube after the fact this is
different this is actually live unless
it's a replay if you have questions or
comments for me that you want me to deal
with use the super chat ask questions
send comments they will pop up on the
screen I will address them personally
during the stream new members and
patrons will get live thank-yous from me
and I will sing your praises and it'll
be amazing david pakman.com slash
membership i will mention I mean I'll
just say this up front because we did
this we did this last time we have a
huge 2019 membership discount the code
is 2019 it'll drop a $60 membership to
2019 $20.19 if we get 10 new members
during the stream i'll open up the phone
lines and people can call in and talk to
me i usually mentioned that like halfway
through i'll just mention it now so that
if people care about that if people want
me to take calls just get going with
those memberships the coupon codes 20 19
10 members david pakman.com slash
membership i will open the phone lines i
won't even give you the number yet
because there's no point in calling in
until i open the phone line so that's a
thing that we we will do if we get 10
new members please don't troll the live
chat i will keep an eye on it
we have moderators obvious trolling and
hate will get you banned if it's subtle
and nobody notices then well you
probably won't get banned because nobody
will notice and lastly yes youtube
membership once again if you do that you
will be recognized live during the
stream are you are people hearing that
because I'm hearing that and I don't
know if when when that happens I don't
know if people are hearing those little
audio things super chat different noise
I think people are probably hearing that
or not we hear it okay very good all
right so let's just get into some of
some of the news that I wanted to talk
about we'll start there and then we'll
get to plenty of other stuff what is
going on here I don't even know what the
right uh okay let's see I guess I have
to close out trying to get trying to
show my screen here
I do that there it is okay very good so
this we are now getting into the phase
of the Trump presidency
let me see if I can zoom this in for
people a little bit more so we can see
it we are getting to the phase of the
Trump presidency where he is now going
to formalize the propaganda briefings
that were previously just sort of
sprinkled through Twitter and press
conferences Donald Trump as of right now
and this could get cancelled who knows
plans to address the nation tomorrow
night about what he says is the crisis
at the us-mexico border now if you
remember already and you got the full
show you saw that I interviewed Scott
Adams today and Dilbert creator Scott
Adams super rich dude Scott Adams
who I guess was a Bernie supporter but
now he thinks a lot of the stuff Trump
is doing is just great I interviewed him
on today's program he said that he tends
to agree with the framing of Donald
Trump with regard to the immigration
crisis I just didn't agree I don't
believe that we have a crisis and what
you really need to understand is that we
know now that fear is one of the biggest
motivators in general to get people to
agree with a policy or to support a
policy make them afraid of something and
then propose a solution and that's I
mean it's we can slice and dice the
quote immigration crisis any way we want
but the bottom line is that it's not a
crisis and to the extent that it's a
problem it's one that mostly is not
going to be solved by the expensive wall
that Donald Trump is proposing so we
have a shutdown right now the shutdown
was promised by Trump as something he
would do and would be proud of doing he
did it we learned from a really good
piece by Jonathan Chait in New York
magazine which came out today I'll be
talking about it extensively on
tomorrow's program the Donald Trump
surprise surprise didn't even really
understand what it meant to do a
government shutdown he didn't understand
that people wouldn't be getting food
stamps he didn't understand that the TSA
wouldn't be getting paid he didn't
understand that it could [ __ ] or shut
down airports
now this is all happening and because
Trump needs to be the alpha male he
can't there's no off-ramp much like with
the tariffs which Trump had no idea
quite frankly how what the end end stage
would be of that Trump has no credible
off-ramp from the government shutdown
over the border wall at this point
because he if he agrees to reopen
government without funding for the wall
he effectively loses these are the terms
that Trump Trump sees everything in
terms of winning and losing right so if
Donald Trump were to were to relent and
reopen government without any money for
the border wall he wouldn't be alpha
anymore which is important to him so
this is a growing disaster and so Donald
Trump is escalating the propaganda war
and he is going to do it with this
address to the nation tomorrow
Trump's primetime address will come amid
a partial government shutdown caused by
his insistence that government that
Congress give him more than five billion
to build a wall on the border
congressional Democrats are refusing to
pay for a wall Trump also plans a trip
Thursday to the southern border to
highlight his demands for the wall Trump
tweets that he will address the nation
at 9:00 p.m. eastern time Tuesday this
why am i calling this a propaganda a
propaganda war effectively the nine p.m.
Eastern Time presidential address to the
nation has taken place in the past for
such events as when President George W
Bush I'm going with recent ones when
President George W Bush announced that
the United States military started
military operations in Iraq okay I
disagreed with that decision but that's
the type of thing that presidents would
announce during one of these nine p.m.
every channel covers it addresses to the
nation when President Obama captured
Osama but I killed Osama bin Laden he
announced that in one of these all the
channels cover it type of evening
addresses so the imagery
of the Oval Office nighttime address
from the White House is oh this is about
something really serious but this isn't
about something really serious we have a
net outflow of undocumented immigrants
to Mexico more are leaving than are
coming in most of the people that are
coming in two-thirds are not coming in
via the physical us-mexico border so
even if a border wall were 100 percent
effective which it would not be you're
only dealing with at most a third of the
problem and people are going out more
quickly than they're coming in at what
cost are we dealing with some fraction
of that one-third that's unclear and in
addition to that of course we actually
know that immigrants documented and
undocumented commit crime at a lower
rate than american-born citizens makes
sense if you know that if you get on the
radar of law enforcement you risk
deportation you're gonna be more likely
to commit crime or less likely to commit
crime obviously less likely to commit
crime we know that's the case
economically the agriculture and
restaurant industries depend on
immigrants documented and undocumented
from Latin America what happens if all
of a sudden you don't have that those
industries fail thanks for the super
supercharged Jackson I will get to that
momentarily and importantly when it
comes to the economics undocumented
immigrants are many of them paying into
the Social Welfare programs that we have
in this country they will never get
anything out because they're
undocumented meaning that economically
in more than one way immigrants even
undocumented immigrants are a net
positive for the economy am i advocating
people commit the crime of crossing into
the country illegally no I'm not but
what I am Telling You is that the border
wall which Trump wants five billion now
but the total cost could be twenty five
thirty five billion in total before it's
all said and done is a poor solution to
a problem that is only a fraction of
what Donald Trump wants us to believe so
again the important thing to keep in
mind is the imagery of Trump sitting
there in the Oval Office
and addressing the nation at 9 p.m. is
to make you think that the the border
wall that he wants to build over which
he is shut down government is a crisis
equivalent to starting a war with
another country for example so it's
important not to fall for it it's I
actually hope that there will be
networks and television channels that
opted not to cover it in the same way
that if Sarah Huckabee Sanders press
secretary in her press briefings doesn't
want to answer questions or wants to do
five minute press briefings or wants to
do them once a month only when she feels
like it when she has some propaganda
talking points
maybe channels will stop covering it
maybe they will live fact-check it I
hope that as many channels as possible
will either not cover this thing and
later mention Trump made the case for
this for this border wall or will live
fact check it at minimum okay that
that's what I would like to see I don't
know if that's the approach that that
they are going to take before I get to
the other story I wanted to discuss
Jackson sent a five-dollar super chat
asking dad wants to know what happens
when you run out of other people's money
love the show I mean I don't even
understand the question what happens
when who runs out of which other
people's money money being used to do
what when and where I mean I don't I I
think it's it's reminiscent of something
that the write likes to say about the
left which is you have all these great
ideas for things to do with other
people's money but it's such a tired and
bogus talking point that I don't I don't
even know how I would begin to address
it okay let's get to the other important
story that I wanted to cover which is
about Supreme Court Justice Ruth Bader
Ginsburg Ruth Bader Ginsburg has missed
maybe maybe I should move this this box
over to the other side maybe this is
taking up some space here there we go
and thanks for the the super chat Roy we
will get to that momentarily
Ruth cater bins burg Ginsburg has missed
Supreme Court arguments for the first
time so
she was in the hospital for surgery not
long ago we learned that even at the
hospital she was working on legal work
for the court
we have talked many many times about
just what a great influence Ruth Bader
Ginsburg has been on the Supreme Court
for progressive values and in so many
other ways the reality of course is and
it's always difficult to know exactly
how you talk about it the reality is
that she is not a young woman she has
had a number of health problems
you never know or I'm sort of dancing
around the obvious here and sort of
using polite language one never knows
how long anyone is going to be able to
stay in their job once they start
getting to a certain age and whenever I
think back to the you know the right is
a lost cause right I mean the right
wants right wing Supreme Court justices
when I think back to the faction of the
left we could call it you know I don't
like to use ad hominem so I don't know
exactly sometimes I call it the Leninist
left although that's kind of a different
left than the one that I'm referring to
here sometimes it's called the useful
idiot left sometimes it's called the
dumb dumb left I don't know exactly what
to call it
but one of the perspectives one of the
points of view that they had was that
the in the end the Supreme Court justice
wasn't Supreme Court justices that the
next president would get to choose we're
not a big enough deal to really say that
even if you don't like Hillary Clinton
you have to prevent Donald Trump from
being President of the United States at
all costs and now when you have Neel
Gorsuch on the court and you have I
already I'm blanking on his name but
Brett Kavanaugh on the court and you
have the possibility that the tenure of
Ruth Bader Ginsburg may end during
Donald Trump's first term if you still
don't realize the importance of being
able to decide who is on that court for
10 20 30 sometimes more years
I don't know what
evidence you would need to see to
convince you of the importance of that
and in the same way that I've said
before I don't really waste much time
really any time trying to convince
people on the right to vote for someone
other than Trump if they are supporting
Trump currently in 2020 I say you're
better off just trying to get the vote
out from people who are already sort of
on your side I don't think it's really
useful to spend much more time trying to
convince the dum-dum left or whatever
you know the useful idiot left the the
Leninists left at the extent that
there's a crossover I don't think I it's
useful to spend too much more time
trying to convince them that hey you
know what we might all say Hillary
wasn't progressive enough for our values
but we would be in far better shape if
she had to and potentially a third
Supreme Court picks then Donald Trump
having them because now even if we get
Trump out in 2020 he impacts the United
States of America in a very specific and
significant way for decades and decades
as a result of his Supreme Court picks I
don't I don't know how you can argue
anything other than that at this point
so Ruth Bader Ginsberg now indeed
missing arguments for the first time in
more than 25 years as she is
recuperating from cancer surgery last
month not on the bench today as the
court met to hear arguments not clear
when she will return the court will hear
more cases tomorrow and the next day and
again next week she is 85 years old
continuing to recuperate work from home
after doctors removed two cancerous
growths from her left lung on December
21st so we wish her the absolute best of
course and if we have any kind of common
sense we recognize the significant
difference between Donald Trump getting
to pick Supreme Court justices and
Hillary Clinton getting to pick Supreme
Court justices let me get to a couple of
other super chats and again as a
reminder if we get ten new members with
this 66% discount code that we have
floating around 29
tene during the stream i'll open up the
phone lines and take calls from people
this is this is just incredible it's
only January 7th and we've already had
233 new members sign up on our website
this this year this month this is by far
the best start we've ever had to any
month we've never had other than ad
pocalypse in April 2017 we have never
had a six and a half day period with two
hundred and thirty three new members I'm
trying to get to 250 as part of this
special you go to david pakman.com slash
membership you select the $60 a year
membership this gets you access to all
the bonus content all of that stuff when
you get an option to put in a coupon
code you just put in 2019
okay zero one nine this will drop the
cost of a yearly membership from $60 to
$20.19 but it's not just for this year
that you can get that price if you want
to keep that discounted price 2019 you
can keep it as long as your membership
remains active if 10 people sign up with
that coupon code okay that's less than
one percent of the people on the stream
right now I'll open the phone lines if
people are hesitant because they don't
want the phone lines opened I will take
a couple of chest challenges from people
on the stream on Leach s org last time I
took two challenges I lost twice it was
sort of embarrassing I'm not that good
at chess but it's fun I will do either
or both if we get those ten memberships
in early enough I've got about an hour
for the stream I'm telling you about it
now if we get that going I will do
either or both of those if we do it
early enough and I do want to hear from
from what what's on people's minds in
terms of politics so we'll get the phone
lines opened okay let me get to some of
the super chats because there's a lot of
people here with questions Roy Earle
sent the five Canadian dollar super shot
saying hey David love your work your
interview with Jesse Lee Peterson was
hilarious would you consider doing the
fallen state again I would you know I'm
actually looking right now at when my
next trip to Los Angeles is going to be
because I've got a few pending things
there that I that I want to do again
which is great I was just out there a
bottom
month and a half ago a couple months ago
and I would absolutely get in touch and
offer to come in again because it's so
funny and I I don't take it seriously
I consider the entire thing a silly goof
and I don't consider his program serious
but it's a great time he does the show
out of a place that is it doubles not
only as his radio studio and his TV
studio but it's also a Christian men's
counseling center if you can imagine
that Jesse Lee Peterson from Mississippi
or whatever it is he's from he has he
does counseling of men under the guise
of Christian counseling at this place in
the middle of LA and it's a scene
it's a scene and I would I would be glad
to be back on Savannah Lambert with a
four dollar 99-cent super chat no
question or comment Thank You Terry
James with a $5 super chat should
progressives stop expecting to fall in
love with candidates and vote like
Republicans yeah I mean I I don't know
that the left has a problem of falling
in love with candidates at the broader
level I mean we've seen you know there
was a sort of cult of personality around
Hillary Clinton there was a cult of
personality around Bernie Sanders you
had the kind of pragmatic left who said
I'll support whoever is most aligned
with my views in the primary but then
I'm going to vote for whoever wins
ultimately because they're all better
than Trump you had some people who opted
not to vote when their guy or gal didn't
win the primary you have a small faction
that may be voted for Bernie and then
ultimately voted for Trump although I
think it's very very small so I agree I
think that we listen these are elected
officials and as much as I agree with
Elizabeth Warren's politics on a lot of
issues I've met her a couple times and
she struck me as not genuine I mean I've
said it before I wasn't like wow this is
just such an amazing person and I look
up to her so much she seemed like a
calculating politician who even was
quote behind the scenes of the interview
I did with her in person did not come
off as a
a genuine person do I blame her not
really a lot of it is probably
protecting oneself in a sort of general
sense but listen I mean it's it's do you
you don't need to be sort of in love
with the person you're voting for as a
person as long as they're not doing
things as a person that directly
conflict with what their stated values
are so like you know with Trump we have
we have several examples of that okay
let me see
cucked by Pat sent a donation very very
clever the sand box bandit sent a
donation of $1 with no question or
comment thank you
Jackson sent a $5 super chat what should
the u.s. is response be to China
removing presidential term limits how
should we treat the president that's
actually a good question so the response
should not be to do the same thing here
you might remember that Donald Trump
said something along the lines of maybe
we'll look at doing that here someday or
something along those lines yeah we
shouldn't do that but I do think that in
the same way that when we deal with Kim
jong-un or we deal with air Dewan or we
deal with Putin I mean obviously not how
Trump deals with them but like normal
presidents when normal presidents deal
with some of those individuals we
understand that they are not exactly
what we would call democratic Democratic
leaders in some cases they were quote
democratically elected in elections of
sort of a questionable questionable
validity or fairness but I think that it
we should we should not pretend that the
Chinese president is the same as you
know the Prime Minister of Canada in
terms of the type of government that
that they represent mark Goodbody has
sent a ten British pound super chat the
biggest super chat of the evening saying
Trump is now talked regarding calling a
state of emergency over his wall funding
is there a chance that if the next
couple of years go really bad for him he
might disrupt the
20s with something similar absolutely so
I got a question on the show I believe
it was last week saying what would
happen if Donald Trump just refused to
accept the result of the Republican
primary if he lost then or the results
of the general election if he lost then
and I said you know ultimately he's
going to need some kind of force in
order to try to stay in office even if
he loses
I can't imagine given what we've seen
from quote the generals who
interestingly enough don't seem to agree
with the guy as much as he seemed to
claim they would during the the campaign
without their support and sort of like
enforcing this staying in power I don't
think that there's any way that it's
going to happen I don't think it's
really something we should talk about
that being said we should anticipate
that Donald Trump in the same way that
when he gets desperate now when the
indictments start coming in he starts to
distract the thon and all of this other
stuff we should expect that he is going
to pull high jinks during the Republican
primary and if he wins it certainly in
the lead-up to the general election if
indeed it's not it's not going well so
we just need to be prepared for it it's
going to you know people's general
understanding of what's going on in the
world comes through media so it's
actually going to be incumbent upon
media not to allow so-called the bogus
October surprises to take over the
presidential election in a way that
trumple used to his advantage vapor wave
dashing sent a five-dollar super chat
saying David go on chapo traphouse I'd
be glad to appear if I was asked RIBA P
has sent a $25 super chat the biggest
super chat of the evening no question or
comment thank you very much
nice two three four seven asks what's
the worst-case scenario for the
government shutdown a worst-case
scenario for the government shutdown is
airports shut down and air travel ceases
grinding the economy to a halt yet
that's actually the worst case scenario
I don't I don't know I need that I need
to go too much further okay before I get
to more super chats I
mention that we have let's see how many
new members here Michael Batista thank
you for signing up
Benjamin Lynch thank you for signing up
Jonathan Lego or leg alt depending on
how you pronounce it new member thank
you for signing up and Takuma easel n'd
new member using the coupon code 2019 on
our website that's for when we get 10
new members I will open up the phone
lines if people want and hear from
people I will play a couple games of
chess against viewers if people want
that maybe both if we do it soon enough
I think we if we're gonna do both we
probably need to get to 10 new members
that's only six more in the next
probably five or ten minutes so you can
use the coupon code 2019 to drop the
price of a membership to just $20.19 for
the year let me see if I can even pull
it up just to show you what I'm talking
about and where one would go about
entering this code I think I can show
you that here we go
you go to our website okay you have to
switch this over to yearly I get emails
from people all the time saying David
I'm getting a message that the coupon
code is invalid and I always say were
you trying to apply a yearly coupon code
to a monthly membership switch at E
early hit the signup button and on the
second page you will see coupon code you
taught me go back here you type in 2019
and then when you hit sign up you will
see that the price drops from $60 a year
down to $20 and 19 cents a year with the
coupon okay that's looking a little
weird maybe because I highlighted it but
that's how it works all right so thanks
to the four people who have already
signed up if we get six more I will open
the phone lines and we will hear from
people via voice gr with a five dollar
super jet Big D Z no love for the DT
drop in mic be easy tick-tock ask for
socks and some locks for DT s bid P
incoherent yeah it be DS
love gr thank you very much completely
incoherent as we have come to expect and
love over the years from gr Sam Boorstin
with a $5 super chat if the shutdown
goes on for many months he is crazy and
I think it will then what happens to our
country
nothing good Sam nothing good and not
only does it start to imperil
the entire aviation industry both
because of TSA not getting paid and
because of the potential shutdown that
we're looking at of the nation's
airports which would [ __ ] I mean so
many industries in the United States it
gets really bad and part of the problem
is that Donald Trump like with most of
his ideas stumbles into them without
really understanding the full impact and
what we're seeing now is exactly what we
would predict which is he's taken aback
by how bad it's getting he didn't know
all this stuff would happen and he is
unable to create a sort of credible
off-ramp without accepting not getting
funding for the wall which was the
reason for this entire thing from the
beginning a Joe Rader with a ten dollar
super chat add to the list of shutdown
consequences Trump is ignorant of
aerospace services such as various
agencies licensing and supporting US
private sector rocket launches you're
right
I don't think Trump cares much about
that I think that's pretty low on his
list sadly Reba P with a second $25
super chatted do you think Trump may be
in cahoots stirring up a war to legally
use national emergency I believe he
would he's that low I would not put
anything past him at this point Reba no
question about it and we will be talking
about this possibility that's been
floated of Trump using the pretext of a
national emergency to effectively
commandeer funding for the border wall
Terry James with a $5 super chap can we
change the conversation on immigration
instead of having the myth of a crisis
be the default narrative that's what I'm
trying to do Terry and today in my
interview with Dilbert cartoonist Scott
Adams by the way it bums me out so much
that one of my favorite cartoons comic
store
growing up now is is this written by
drawn by a guy who I feel like has sort
of really been led astray in terms of
his politics but we had a fruitful and
productive conversation today although I
don't know that his mind has been
changed yeah I'm making the case and I
made it to Scott Adams today that I
don't believe there is a crisis and
that's the pretext that we need to upend
to begin with
no Wilk about Nabila Kivar II $5 super
chat no question or comment Thank You
Karl
Floyd graph with a two euro super chat
should Americans living abroad have to
pay taxes oh man I am sort of mixed on
this but generally speaking I believe
that if you if you earn the money
working for a non-american company and
you're not living in the United States
for any of the year I don't think you
should have to pay taxes in the u.s.
that that's my we could get into the
details but that's my general view Roy
Earle with a ten Canadian dollar super
chat David do you think the regime in
Iran will survive in the next 20 years
or will domestic unrest and
technological change ultimately dissolve
the theocracy and dinosaurs ruling the
country right now I'm actually pretty
optimistic that it is going to be
dissolved and the reason for that is
that Iran's younger population which is
quite large is is quite secular that
doesn't mean atheist but it means
separation of church and state and as
they gain political capital over time I
am optimistic that they will dis disarm
the current regime that exists there
before I get to more super chats let me
thank Patrick Butler our fifth new
member of the evening we're halfway to
ten if we get to ten new members at
david pakman.com slash membership I'll
open up the phone lines and/or play
chess against people in the audience
probably will be crushed again but
that's okay if you want a membership for
two-thirds off the normal rate we're
doing this for
oh just probably another day or two
until we get 250 new subscribers for the
month you can use the coupon code 2019
on our website that will
a $60 membership to $20.19 five more and
we will open up the phone lines okay
aviation geek with a five euro forty
nine super chat will the Republican
Party suffer in future elections because
of Trump's presidency two possible paths
one is yes the other is that the
Republican Party as it gets worse and
worse for Trump if indeed 2019 is going
to be the worst year of his life the
Republican Party successfully distances
themselves and they kind of pretend like
they're the solution to trump rather
than the problem that allowed him to
come to power so it could could go
either way
Eagles nation David will there be a 2008
part two because of Trump I don't
pretend to have any greater economic
prediction powers than any of the
economists who are clueless and always
get it wrong but what I've been saying
for years is that we are due for a
financial downturn and the policy of
Donald Trump could accelerate it and
make the bottom worse than it would have
otherwise been that that's basically as
far as I can go now Austan eggy man
Agyeman not sure how it's pronounced $2
super job your thoughts on worker coops
thanks David
I love worker coops I think that they're
great I don't support the government
imposing that all businesses must be
structured as worker coops with
socialized ownership that I am not in
favor of which is why I consider myself
a social democrat rather than a
socialist but there are many great
examples of worker coops some
interesting ones in Spain is one place
where my former college professor
Richard Wolff has explored and I am all
for worker coops uh let's see here be
still well sent a $2.00 super chat
saying just hell yeah that's right hell
yeah I appreciate that a nice two three
four seven Trump cult ever see anything
like it in politics I mean you know I I
try to avoid
claiming that everything is
unprecedented and we've never seen
anything like this before but there are
certainly unprecedented elements about
what's currently going on and I do think
that you know George W Bush had a pretty
detached from the facts cult of
personality around him but it was sort
of more related to his born-again sort
of stuff with evangelicals the Trump
detachment from reality cult is
different and it's certainly worse the
show
sent a $20 Super chap David could we
conceivably levy attacks on large
companies that applies after net profits
are calculated what rules if any could
help lower tax avoidance around the
aforementioned tax also potatoes are
boss I'm I don't know if potato is a
metaphor for something here but I I I
love a good potato sure made a great
salmon chowder last night with some
great purple potatoes can you imagine
okay so the idea is net attacks on net
profits that avoids reducing well no I
mean so I'm not exactly sure I know what
you mean because net profits are of
course influenced by deductions that
reduce adjusted income so that's what we
have now I mean it's a tax on net income
the reason net income is so low in many
cases is because of the loopholes and
deductions that exist so I think to
lower tax avoidance you just have to get
rid of some of those mechanisms for
deducting from the business's income if
I'm misunderstanding I apologize okay
we've got several more new members
Alexandra Bogert has signed up on our
website Marc Goodbody has signed up on
her website and Andre Bradshaw is the
newest david pakman show member using
the 2019 coupon code to more okay two
more new members on our website and I
will open up the phone lines if we want
to get some calls in it would be good
I'm just saying because I do have to
make dinner in a little bit it would be
good to
get those last two members in sooner
than later
Eagles nation dollar 99 Nick Foles is
better than Tom Brady sorry David Tom
Brady's the greatest of all time
so I don't don't find too much else
discussion necessary here King coyote
$10 super chat hey David why does the
right hate when government gets involved
with private businesses but are fine
with private businesses getting involved
with government via lobbying and
campaign contributions oh because
they're hypocrites and everything they
say is merely a political football meant
to gain influence in the way that they
want and influence government in the way
that they see as the as what they want
as aligned with their political beliefs
it's all political footballs debt and
deficit draining the swamp the the
border wall is a metaphor for a sort of
alpha male big-boy stuff that Trump is
trying to do none of it is actually
about what they claim that it's about
and that's why they can do a and then do
the opposite of a and then criticize
everybody else because they're
criticizing that I mean it's it's just a
shell game quite frankly best pay with a
$2 super chat the left push for a UFO
disclosure hashtag free energy I don't
know what that is I don't know what that
means
but maybe someday I will know a 350
pilot are you a real a 350 pilot that's
cool if we have a real a 350 pilot in
the audience I almost flew the a350 over
the summer from Boston to Munich
Lufthansa's flying in a 350 and it got
delayed like two hours very early on and
I ended up getting I would have missed
my connection to Copenhagen Copenhagen
some say and I ended up getting moved
over to Swiss Air and it wasn't an a350
it was less exciting it was a plane I'd
flown on before a 350 pilot says hasn't
I lost it here hasn't haven't US
companies suffered from the Iran
sanctions example Boeing lost a huge
contract with Iran
and azam on airlines yes I mean it's
it's certainly possible that there are
US companies that have suffered from
Iran sanctions although I don't know too
much about that specific example
Cedric Woodson says support what you do
bro keep bringing it thank you Joe radar
interesting Trump Russia angle u.s.
currently plate pays Russia 81 million
per astronaut for a roundtrip ticket to
the International Space Station the
shutdown will easily delay SpaceX dm1
launch this month and more human
launches later this year indeed I don't
think Trump cares about that
Eagles nation do I think young Iranians
will change Iran yes I do this is beta
Saad betas budget is God is the fact
that left-wing politics often need to
rely on some form of external morality
to make convincing arguments detrimental
compared to the egoist arguments that
come from the law non religious right I
don't agree that there is listen X all
morality is external in a sense I
understand what you're saying that the
right likes to pretend that their
morality is not but I I don't think I
agree with the framing of the question I
think that just the left is often not
good about talking about values okay we
got a whole bunch of new members so I am
going to get set up to take some phone
calls here I will let you know when you
can call in I will let people queue up
as the phrase is let me just turn got to
get logged in here Oh
something went black here and this is
not good let me uh boy what is going on
there let me see if I can how can I do
this hmm something weird may happen on
screen let me see how I can manage this
okay that didn't work let's see what why
does that keep going back black when I'm
typing stuff in okay let me get the
phones open here voicemail off six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty
okay that's the number six one seven
eight three zero forty seven fifty I
will let people start to call in
and I will go through some of these
other super chats and then I'll pick up
on some calls Roy Earle asks what do you
think could end the civil war in Yemen
well from the point of view of the US
maybe finally putting our foot down on
Saudi Arabia that would be a good step
Jackson follow up to the China president
question how do we treat dictators that
are pivotal to the stability of Commerce
well you have to not do what Trump is
doing basically which is simultaneously
playing the tough guy but allowing
yourself to be manipulated and creating
a total lack of credibility with foreign
leaders who say why are we dealing with
this guy he says one thing then he backs
out of it and quite frankly I think that
that applies to all all foreign leaders
regardless of whether they are dictators
are democratically elected or sort of in
between as is the case in many countries
elisa Griscom asks or just says David I
really enjoy your show and the topics
discussed keep it up thank you a 350
pilot says I fly the e 194 to e Belgium
but my dream is the a350 all right well
I hope you achieve your dream let's see
let's see who's on the phones here um
but but but uh why don't we okay first
let me get myself dialed in here and
then we should be able to take some
calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 calls are
starting to stack up should just be a
moment just getting myself logged in
it's it's quite a quite an impressive
phone system we have here ok let's see
let's just go to the first person that
called in from the 941 area code caller
from 941 who's this my name's fallin
from Tampa Bay area hey Paul would spire
had a few questions though like those
your opinions on alright maybe there's a
lot of people holding we could just
maybe you're just your most important
question we could do today ok ok
what do you think about the idea that I
think it's income inequality and
economic anxiety is continuously
increasing I think at some point there's
going to be a breaking point some point
there's going to be I want say a
revolution but something's gotta give
that's Marxism what are you right I mean
that that's effectively that that's the
the the idea of Marxism one of the ideas
is that the unfairness of the economic
system that is capitalism will
eventually become untenable and it will
cause something like an uprising slash
revolution yeah I mean so is it going to
happen I don't know I agree with you
that there are so many negative
externalities to the inequality that
we're experiencing that something at
some point is going to break now will it
be a Marxist revolution I happen to
think it won't but yeah I mean your your
perspective is in line with many
economic and economic philosophers over
the last hundred and fifty years all
right thank you really appreciate the
call six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty let's go next to I
have someone in our caller ID as Co June
I don't know if that's if that's right
but if that sounds right that's who's on
are you there hey yeah yeah where is it
June Oh No who John who John ok sorry we
have it incorrect and I will I will fix
it cou John thank you thanks so much
so my question had to do with on third
parties and I wanted to ask your opinion
on whether the Democrats like Bernie
Sanders well Bernie Sanders non
democratic but whether he said the
progressive [ __ ] go about trying to take
over the Democratic Party or just start
a new party oh okay yeah good question
so my view on this is you can't just
take one strategy and and use that one
because it's it's sort of a double-edged
sword on the one hand if progressives
abandoned the Democratic Party and say
we're just going to focus
third parties unless we fix campaign
finance and some kind of rank-choice
voting third parties don't stand a
chance so that's a losing strategy if we
just focus on the Democratic Party and
putting progressivism in the Democratic
Party and we forget about the fact that
we've got to fix the system to break the
two-party duopoly we also lose so you
really just have to do both and the late
great Tim carpenter from progressive
democrats of america who sadly passed
away a few years ago was a great friend
of the show and a great progressive
activist he oh he called it an inside
outside strategy I don't think he
developed that but that's who I think of
when I hear the question you asked and
you've got to do both so I have a
rebuttal to that ok um with the recent
passing of Pago we've seen even
basically all of the progressives fold
we had 3 progressives rule kana Tulsi
Gabbard and then Alexander Carson Cortes
you know voting notes to pay goes they
basically just ruined their whole
strategy to plant Medicare and yeah I
mean so ok I don't disagree with the
fact that you're saying I just don't see
how that means that progressives should
abandon the Democratic Party and just
try to win third party because the fact
that those three people change their
mind on that issue doesn't tell us that
just saying we're gonna focus on third
party is a winning strategy I think it's
still a losing strategy but don't how
how big the hug I guess how powerful the
force that they're really taking on I
mean if we have progressives voting to
the Democratic Party and leadership of
Nancy Pelosi like that is that's just
ridiculous
or you could call it pragmatic and that
they're going to pick their battles and
that they recognize that this was not
the time I mean that listen there's
there's a lot of different ways we could
interpret it I just don't think it gets
us to saying that abandoning the
Democratic Party and saying we're only
going to focus third party that that
doesn't
make that a winning strategy and I think
it literally cannot work given the
current campaign finance system COO John
appreciate the call I hope to hear from
you again let's go next to the five five
one area code and if I may five five one
if you just hold on for one second I do
want to thank Derrick Moran for signing
up as a member and Melissa Mekel we for
signing up as a member and Uzziah
Drayton and Lydia pickin and Matthew our
venetus and I think I already mentioned
Andre Bradshaw so I apologize five five
one five five one go ahead hey David big
sound so thank you so we you've got a
horrible connection I heard you you you
were taking responsibility for something
but I didn't hear what it was can you
tell me again for all the UFO super-shot
you okay got it got it so we burn UFOs
or what's going on yeah so my whole
thing is I'm a big social democrat big
aggressive I think the most urgent
issues are like the green new deal right
living wage etc but at the same time I
think that the same way we pushed for
government transparency involving other
areas like campaign finance donations or
illegal Wars yep we should be doing the
same thing for the UFO topic because
recently it's not becoming a fringe like
moving your name we're like New York
Times The Washington Post all reported
on the recent secret Pentagon you have
no program because taxpayer money into
it so I believe that we should know
what's going on you know do you believe
that there's been contact between an
alien race and humans well that's that's
another conversation I think there's I
don't think that's have been really
involved when it comes to a more
government approach because right now
all we know for sure
I got factual information is that we
have we're pretty clearly been visited
by craft with technology that are not
seen on earth right now so if you cross
let's see I don't want it I don't want
let's not get ahead of ourselves okay so
if we've been visited by craft with
technology that is
not human technology whose technology is
it yeah that and also why can't we use
that technology updates no no no I I
wasn't asking that rhetorically I'm
asking you it you're saying you're not
you're stopping short of saying we've
been visited by aliens but we've been
visited by technology out of this earth
you know you don't know this alien that
I could be some foreign government in
our airspace but means that we deserve
to know where the technology is coming
from what do you think I'm now I'm just
asking for your opinion do you believe
that alien species have come to earth
have made contact in some way I
personally do believe that but at the
same time I wouldn't push that as the
main thing to talk about having no
apparent okay you wouldn't push it but
let me push it a little bit why do you
think it is that we haven't seen the
evidence of that has it been covered up
well we're seeing it right now so I
believe like confirmation is like
happening now with because I could hang
in your time to report that like Louis
fallodon doe with the head of the
Pentagon programming no no I don't want
to get off track I do have people
holding off track the New York Times
article doesn't say we've been visited
by alien species so what I want to ask
you is why have has the information not
gone public that we've been visited by
aliens because I don't think that they
know how to deal with it they who I
think the government the government
doesn't know how to deal with the visits
from aliens or if it's another
government technology no government it's
not aliens
so is it aliens or is a government
technology like I don't we all know so
what we saw was under said that the US
government does not currently have that
technology that's anything that all
right what would change your mind what
would change your mind that and make you
take the position that we haven't been
visited by aliens if the government says
that this technology has actually been
our technology or another government
technology that had couldn't they
couldn't they just be lying if they want
to hide it from people they could they
could so then would that convince you
something like that convinced you yeah I
could say a little bit
only because Verner von Braun who was
ahead of him to first East our NASA he
was part of Project Paperclip he was
brought from the Nazis over after the
war he said first it was first it was
Russia then it was the terrorists and
then it was aliens as in like false
flags wouldn't it be a little isn't it a
little weird though that you on the one
hand are saying we need media to expose
the fact that the government hasn't been
honest with us about this alien
technology but then at the same time
you're saying oh if the government just
said this is our technology you would
just believe them like how if if the
whole problem yeah hold on a second a
second if the whole problem is that this
has been a multi-decade conspiracy to
keep this secret that the government has
done that would be a very dishonest
government why would you just say oh
they said it's their technology got it
I'm sure now they're telling the truth
that doesn't make sense does it no it
doesn't I think anything that the
government says with a grain of salt so
then why would you just be satisfied by
them saying it's it's their technology
oh wow I'm not I wouldn't be satisfied
think you just did would be a bigger
deal no you just said you would be
satisfied with that
okay all right thank you for the call
appreciate it very very interesting
stuff okay six one for area code who's
there from six one four what's going on
well that's you well thank you we can
hear you fine hey hey my name's Anne
Hill I'm from Columbus Ohio okay and I
just um one of someone else had already
touched on my question a little bit I'm
fairly new to politics I would say like
since Trump presidency um like just now
again in politics now I was gonna ask
you about the third party because I kind
of don't like what either party is doing
when it comes to like political rhetoric
okay but um you can already answer that
with the other guys question I was going
to ask so my question is does it make
sense I'm kind of I lean more towards
the conservative side oh you do that
yes yeah um so let me ask you you said
you got into politics around Trump what
was it appealed to you and got you into
politics um I think yeah with my age and
just awareness it's um it's not exactly
Trump but I mean there's a hundred
things I could dislike about Trump I'm
very open-minded but I kind of like the
conservative party values but recive huh
like what conservative values speak to
you um the values of women in government
when it comes to like my community
because I'm african-american hold on I
just I don't want to skip over that oh
yeah what what what consume what if
conservatives done about women in
government what was that no oh oh
limited I thought you said women the
government care about limited government
okay one minute yeah eliminate
government cutting taxes just the
distant if you like you know social
programs like that I'm not for like
eliminating social programs but I think
there should just be a certain
limitation but although I do like the
ideas of progressive so I would almost
say like I'm a conservative progressive
I don't know if that makes sense it
doesn't really I'm wondering if maybe
and I say this with total peace and love
is it possible that and I have a lot of
friends who have recently gotten into
politics and they sort of not they're
not really sure exactly where where they
actually are on the political spectrum
like one one of my friends study was a
Republican and he agrees with Bernie on
everything and then he said what am i
doing I don't I don't even know what's
going on is it possible that your
political views have just not developed
enough or have become nuanced enough yet
for you to really know where you are on
the political spectrum is that at all
possible um yes yeah that is very
possible um I mean I it's something I'm
really interested now I'm just many
hours of each night you know yep doing
research on
both sides you know and I found you when
I found you about a week ago
oh yeah it was about a week ago and I'm
like I went through like most of your
videos and like almost a night you know
not most of home but now of course as a
conservative did you find yourself
disagreeing with most of the things that
I was saying no you didn't you might not
be a conservative you know because
concert' I can assure you if you look at
my inbox and my tweets conservatives
don't agree with what I'm saying that's
because they played a party part thing
that I knew the most of the videos I've
seen you were talking about like things
Trump wants to do and in a sense like
you know you my god this is ridiculous
this pull out the facts and that's what
appealed to me when it comes to
conservatives the first conservative
that I actually you know was started to
view with ben shapiro so I started to
listen to Ben Shapiro ideas and I was
like you know makes sense you got
statistics facts or whatever and you
know that's what that's where I kind of
lead towards that and I've never
actually listened for Democrats or I
don't like using a party names I'm just
saying like you know a Democrat that
actually had like kind of facts or
that's and so what you know I don't know
if you would consider yourself a
Democrat or I don't know if that's
different from progressive or yeah so I
mean a registered Democrat but I'm a
progressive person politically okay but
yeah I kind of like yeah I love what
you're saying and I mean recently
listened to like Roland Martin that's
another one and I'm yeah I'm just like
huh I kind of like this uh progress
stuff I mean I like the the principles
you know the progression of America I
kind of don't like the back-and-forth
that's going on right now either party
okay very good will welcome to politics
I'm thrilled you found a show and I hope
to hear from you again I'm gonna pick up
on a couple other people's calls all
right okay all right thank you I
appreciate it okay thank you very much
okay let's check in with Dante from
Florida Dante from Florida what's going
on
Dontae you might have us on mute I'm not
sure
hey it's actually Don Selleck sorry
about that hey how are you um I'm good
so um you know I called last week and
asked the question about Alexandria
Carter
yep details here don't worry we've got a
whole file on you so um this week as a
fellow leftist progressive populist
leftist whatever you want to call it um
I want to know what your opinion is on
Elizabeth Warren so since she came on
the scene the 2010-2013 you know she's
obviously been the second best Senator
in the country um and she's you know
supported a lot of very good suppressive
policies but do you think that her
standing in your own opinion has has
fallen because of her recent
miscalculations when it comes to
politics and her inaction or just her
the way that she isn't out front on
certain progressive priorities evening
that yeah yes yes I do think sigh I
think that Elizabeth Warren has had a
reduction in her profile as a result of
some miscalculations that have been made
I think listen it's too early to tell
and she when I take my political
alignment test I'm most aligned with
Bernie and right behind Bernie is
Elizabeth Warren so her politics and my
politics are very very much in line so
this is not a criticism of her politics
but the entire DNA thing I think was
miscalculated it was weird
I don't exactly know I mean I get the
idea was get it out of the way so that
now she can announce that she's running
for president I think it was it was sort
of strange I think that she has been
successfully framed as not as as much of
an authority on a lot of these important
political issues as she probably should
be considered based on her knowledge and
experience in many areas so I do
think that Elizabeth Warren has taken a
bit of a hit in terms of the public
perception of her yeah all right yeah so
um that thing here's my question
and so another question I had was and
thoughts about Elizabeth Warren do you
think wasn't really a question it's more
of what I've my I guess come to Jesus
moment even though I don't really
believe in you well Don Taylor got a
question in and I've got a bunch of
people holding and yeah let's do that
one next time I appreciate the call
Dante from Florida always get great to
hear from him let's go to our caller
from the four for three area code caller
from four for three what's going on this
is me that's you hey David how's it
going good good how are you good um my
question for you is I just want to get a
little bit of insight on the matter we
know that there are a lot of a good
chunk of Trump supporters under no
circumstances will they ever leave him
do you think for those people do you
think they admired Trump the president
or some celebrity given his background
before entering politics well the the
question would be different before the
election and now I mean the Trump's
celebrity caused him to grow his base in
a way that without his celebrity he
wouldn't have been able to do but now
that he is president there's a cult of
personality around Trump that is beyond
his celebrity status and it's just you
know rich business dude who talks like
he's an alpha male and he's gonna do
stuff so I think that the celebrity
helped at the beginning I think it's
less of a factor now mm-hmm I see
yeah right all right no problem thank
you glad glad I was able to answer that
for you let's go next to our caller from
the eight one eight area code caller
from eight one eight what's going on
hello yeah that's you we're not on
speaker are we yes it is bad and I think
the answer is no good all right yeah
yeah
Hey so um I just wanted to ask you right
now an article from the intercept that
was just written yesterday and January
said and it says right here US Senate's
first bill in the midst of the shutdown
is a bipartisan defense of the Israeli
government for a boycott and it's called
HR 1 and basically what it is is it's a
bill that will stop not necessarily make
it illegal to criticize the State of
Israel but rather to make it illegal to
boycott the product and the Senate has
already have over 70 people have kind of
approve of this so I just kind of wanted
to get your take as to why we have to
kind of you know give oil tea almost to
the State of Israel I haven't seen the
article but so I'm trying to figure out
I'm going only by what you're telling me
to be clear you said it wouldn't make it
illegal to criticize Israel but it would
make it basically illegal what were the
exact words you said yeah so basically
the bill is called HR 1 and it was
actually passed by the Senate during the
shutdown you know supposedly the
government is under a shutdown but they
were actually able to pass this bill at
least in the Senate we don't know if
it's going to go through the house but
it's called HR 1 and it says here that
it's going to make it illegal to boycott
Israeli product it's kind of like an
anti BDS bill and we've heard of course
in Texas with the the Islamic teacher
who was basically fired from her job her
name is uh by bhaiya what Tia sucked
like that and she was on shiridi society
the boycott good product in Israel and -
she was she refused to give her a pledge
to Israel and she was she got fired from
her job as you probably heard so I just
kind of wanted to let you know or kind
of wanted to ask you why why this is you
know what do you think about this so I
need to look into what you're talking
about because a lot of the things you're
saying just aren't quite making sense so
who would go to prison
so what people would go to prison if
they criticized Israel is that what
you're saying mark pretty much did you
say yeah yeah there's no way that that's
what the bill says I'm gonna look into
that I mean in the house HR 1 is is a
House Democrats introduced
anti-corruption bill that's what HR 1 is
in a house maybe it's something totally
different in the Senate but I I'm gonna
look into this
I can't imagine anyone's going to jail
for criticizing Israel I just I I would
reread that bill maybe okay well perfect
and the articles had it pretty much it's
a bipartisan support for the State of
Israel that will make it pretty much
illegal to boycott I'm concerned about
the use of terms like pretty much
because pretty much could mean anything
and you're saying people would go to
prawns going to prison if they if they
criticized Israel I just I'm gonna look
into it okay I just don't know enough
about it to comment and what you're
telling me isn't sounding exactly right
okay well either way that's at least
that's what I'm reading here in the
article is basically an anti you heard
of EDS right yes I am yeah this is
basically this is an anti BDS bill
essentially that the Centers pretty much
already I mean it already has like 60
votes like I said well it had 70 votes
now you're saying it is 50 you're saying
it's yeah we need to see ours about
criticism now you're saying it's about
bi let me tell you what I'm gonna look
at the world is I'm not really getting a
grasp of what's going on from from your
description of it is that fair sure sure
yeah I was waiting through the article
and and yeah sorry my mistake it wasn't
70 it was I got 60 vote no it's six okay
god alright thank you for the call very
much appreciate it I will look into that
I've got to run I've actually I've got
to get I've got a I've got to get to the
grocery store I got to get Dinner
started so I'm glad that I was able to
do a stream I'm glad that people were
able to call in I will stream again
thanks to everybody who signed up
including Luke Brennan and ELISA Griscom
and James Burnside and maybe I mentioned
some of these names Derek Moran
like 25 new members during the stream
thanks to everybody more stream soon
don't don't worry there will be more